because oh my god you have a massive
laceration on your face
and I look down and there's just blood
just cascading down my face onto my
jacket trickling onto my shoe and I go
is it bad she goes it appears to be
quite severe
[Music]
wrong with junior
he's the creator of the webseries secret
weapon
[Music]
I'm going to tell you a story about the
only fight that I've ever been in in my
entire life and it's important to keep
in mind that prior to this the closest I
had ever come was a pillow fight when I
was eight years old against my best
friend and you'd think I would have won
that because he was the nosebleed kid
you guys know these kids writers have
blood gushing out of their head with no
warning whatsoever like we'd be standing
there waiting for the school bus he bent
down to tie his shoe stand up looking
like he just went on a coke bender it
was so bad my mom wouldn't even let him
in the house which was weird growing up
with an indoor cat and out to her friend
but that's the way I had to be so r8
years old we're jumping on his bed
pillows in hand we whack each other the
exact same moment his nose just erupts
but I find out that I am definitely
allergic to goose down so he's got blood
all over the comforter I'm laid out on
the bed with my eyes swollen shut
gasping for air or both screaming for
help my throat closes up my dad has to
rush me to the emergency room I've never
seen him more embarrassed in his life by
the way doctor comes in he was like what
happened to him he was in a fight what
kind of fight I don't see what that's
important
[Laughter]
definitely not a big confidence booster
when you find out that your kryptonite
is feathers you know so cut to 20 years
later I still have a shameful Oh in one
record I'm in the East Village of
Manhattan it's about ten o'clock on a
Thursday night
I just bought some weed and I'm headed
home to Brooklyn so I go down the stairs
of the 2nd Avenue F train station and as
I swipe my card I hear a woman screaming
now if you live in a small town that
might be a cause for concern but in a
city of eight million people some of
them are gonna be screaming it's pretty
much par for the course so I casually
look over and I see a petite young
blonde girl early 20s and holding her
from behind is a guy about my build
maybe mid 30s it's getting a little
rough but I'm like maybe is he doing the
Heimlich maneuver but you can't scream
while you're choking and also he has one
hand on her breast the other hand is
moving between her legs his form is
terrible
I think maybe maybe this is a couple
into some aggressive foreplay anything I
can do to justify not getting involved
right
and then he grabs her by the blouse
whips her against the wall hauls off
punches her in the face
clobbers her she is now sobbing he's
trying to rip her pants off I'm like you
know what I don't think they're together
I think this guy is a rapist someone's
got to stop this guy not gonna be me of
course but somebody and now he grabs her
by the throat slams her head against the
wall and no one is doing anything he
hits her again I'm like I gotta be
that guy
so I yell out the most threatening thing
I can think of which unfortunately is
hey buddy that's a lady
imagine if that's all it took he was
like oh my god it is so ladies it's the
last time I leave the house without my
glasses so as you can imagine has no
effect and he hauls off to hit her again
and I just Hulk out I go come on
let's go it's pretty big jump from a
buddy that's a lady right could've gone
with pick on someone your own size or
I'm telling but it gets his attention
and as he turns to look at me she prized
his hand off her throat bolts through
the turnstile flies up the stairs runs
out of the station she's gonna be okay
but then I turned back to him and he is
pissed I don't know if you guys have
ever a cock-blocker rapist before
but they do not take too kindly to it so
he's just staring me down with these
steely blue eyes and I got to tell you
under normal circumstances beautiful
eyes but right now they're just cold and
terrifying and I'm taking full inventory
of his physical appearance I'm like all
right 510 160 I want to be able to give
a detailed description of the police
when I wake from my medically induced
coma so he takes his first step toward
me and very calmly goes up what you
gonna do and part of me is
tempted to try to talk my way out of
this you know be like hey man I didn't
mean the interfere if you hurry I'm sure
you can catch up with oh I'm tempted but
I don't do that come on come this is
your chance to take this guy out so i
clenched my fists and I start yelling
back the up man back the up
and I can tell you that does not have
much impact when you yourself are
fearfully backing up so I hit the
opposing while he's got me backed into a
corner I got nowhere to go so I have no
choice but to try to take this guy out
so I take a deep breath and I ready
myself and I step in with a demolishing
blow I'm just gonna lay this guy out and
I may have if I wasn't still eight feet
away from him so there's this horrible
moment where I just watch my fist whiz
past his face micro
he steps in clobbers me my knees buckle
but I don't go down like all right
fisticuffs is not my strong suit I'm
gonna come back kick this guy in the
balls play I just completed a woman's
self-defense class
so I step in I swing he scoots back at
the last second I miss his balls but I
get him in the stomach and here's what I
know about my fighting style so far way
too polite can't land a punch and when I
kick someone I make this sound I go not
my proudest moment but I make contact
and he stumbles back and he turns and he
runs out of the station so now I'm
feeling like hot I'm like oh yeah
powerhouse Bruce Lee kick I didn't back
down I took a punch he ran off I think
I'd finally won a fight right and more
importantly I saved that woman I think
I'm the first guy with a mustache to
save a woman from train tracks rather
than tie her to them so now I'm feeling
invincible I'm about to get on the train
to go home and this older woman stops me
she goes oh my god you have a massive
laceration on your face and I look down
and there's just blood just cascading
down my face onto my jacket trickling
onto my shoe and I go is it bad she goes
it appears to be quite severe
and my Adrenaline's pumping so I don't
feel any pain I just feeling warmth and
I kind of like we play everything in my
head and I think well that guy was kind
of holding his hand in a funny way he
didn't really punch me so much as like
swing at me
there's blood everywhere I did not get
punched I did not want to fight I just
got stabbed in the face now I don't know
about you guys but when I get stabbed by
a stranger with a foreign object first
thing that comes to mind oh my god now I
have AIDS I know that's not how it works
you gotta share a glass of water but
right now paranoia was taking hold of me
something oh my god some spiteful psycho
running around the city with an infected
box cutter just filleted my face I just
have aids coursing through my veins I
think you know what maybe it won't take
hold if I'm bleeding it all how so I
actually lean over go rid yourself yet
out of me and the same woman she goes
what are you doing she reaches into her
purse grabs a lot of napkins slaps them
on my face cuz you know every woman over
30 is a surplus of person adkins and she
leaves me up in the street calls 9-1-1
dozen cops on the scene within minutes
they all want to see the cut so one
after another I remove the napkins each
time another Pinal blood spurts out and
they all have the same reaction there's
go put it back put it back so another
cop rolls up and he goes hey do you mind
if I see it his partner goes you see his
mouth just picture another one right
next to it so all these cops are
swarming around and I remember I got
that corner on it's a weed in my
backpack
you know this is New York this is not
the weed topia you burnouts are you sick
it's not like and show the guy my
medical card he's like oh cool I have
one too all right so justifiably I'm
freaking out and I feel this big mitt on
my shoulder and my God my god he can
smell it I'm him going to jail
he spins me around and his detective
goes hey how's it feel to be a goddamn
hero
it reaches into his back pocket hands me
his business card he goes you ever need
anything you ever in a jam you call me I
got your back I was like I may take you
up on that a little sooner than you
think so
so ambulance finally shows up I'm in the
hospital I'm getting stitched up and I
listen to a lot of rap music I hear a
lot of references to a buck fifty and a
buck fifty is a facial laceration that
requires 150 stitches and I don't know
if you can see the scar right here right
there is it is it a mere 23 stitches
which has to make you wonder what kind
of facial laceration requires a
hundred and fifty I think that's
decapitation no need to be alarmed sir
we'll simply sew your head back on
you'll be good to go
so ten days later I get my stitches out
I seem to be healing up nicely and that
night I'm brushing my teeth and I
noticed this clear liquid dripping into
my scar and my god just residual wound
goop no big deal it keeps up for a few
days I go back to the doctor and it
turns out when this guy cut me
he hit my salivary gland so I'm now
drooling out of the side of my face
a little dribble buckets a drool every
time I see food like you put a plate of
wings in front of me I'm just a
slobbering Saint Bernard
which is ironic cuz I'm a dog walker at
the time so I'm just roaming the streets
of New York with a pack of dogs in tow
you're looking at me like oh he's one of
us now it was so bad I could push on the
Glen and shoot it across the wall too
bad I didn't have that at the time of
the attack right back do it so now I'm
just feeling terrible this is just a
misery I'm like I just run off and join
the Coney Island freak show Chloe with a
SuperSoaker face so two weeks goes by
and it finally stops drooling stops I go
back to the doctor he said all right I
think you're finally out of the woods
all you gots that nifty looking scar
Halloween's around the corner let me
guess you're gonna go as the Joker I was
like well the Joker has a scar both
sides of his face so unless I go out and
stop a left-handed rapist I don't know
man but it all has a happy ending
I am fine obviously it turns out he did
not give me AIDS had it all along
girl got away and they actually caught
the guy they caught the guy three days
after the whole thing happened they
found him right outside the same station
remember I thought he was my age 54 year
old drunk homeless man so 20 years older
than he looks beautiful baby blues I got
my ass kicked by the world's sexiest
wino so he's currently in prison he got
sentenced to 15 years of having a home
and people asked me if I'm worried about
him coming after me when he gets out
it's like well he's gonna be 70 years
old so unless he watches this in prison
and comes out from me with a pillow
[Music]
pretty sure that's a fight I can win